(gypsy music)
- [Voiceover] Did she just
make full eye contact?
Definitely no one behind me.
- Want a free sample?
- Hey.
BuzzFeed presents Is She Flirting?
Or Just Being Nice?
- Do you like to cook?
- I, yeah, I love it.
- They go great on pies or on salads,
and they're gluten free.
- I didn't know that.
- [Voiceover] Huh. Sounds like she's
taking an interest in my personal life.
- Well, do you live with anyone?
Should you buy for two?
- Oh, I uhh...
- [Voiceover] Is she trying
to figure out if I'm single?
She could just be trying
to sell me apples.
- You know, has anyone ever told you
you look like another person?
- [Voiceover] I do look
like a relatable Matt Damon.
- Normally, I could only
give people one free sample,
but you can have as many as you want.
- [Voiceover] Does that
mean what I think it means?
- There is a great bar just around
the corner that I go to all the time.
You should totally check it out.
- OK, uh, when?
- Whenever.
- [Voiceover] Alright, I'm in.
That's a clear invitation,
definitely going to ask her out.
Next week.
- So good to meet you Patrick.
- Yeah, bye.
- Peter! You came back!
So good to see you!
Have as many free samples as you want.
- Thanks.
- Did you go check out that bar?
Subscribe for more wonderful things.